hasta ahora hemos visto los fondos
mutuos de inversión abierta que pueden
como que crecer y encogerse dependiendo
de cuántos inversionistas que quieran
invertir en el fondo y puede crecer al
crear nuevas acciones y vendiéndolas al
público en general y pueden encogerse
porque alguien que quiera su dinero de
vuelta va al fondo y dice hey tienes que
comprarme esto de regreso ok en el book
valor unitario de la cuota parte por
acción pero el problema con esto es que
de hecho de hecho hay un par de
problemas es que el administrador
siempre debe conservar un poco de
efectivo apartado en caso de que alguno
de los inversionistas llegue con él y
diga quiero comprar mi acción de vuelta
quiero liquidez y la otra cosa es que al
menos desde el punto de vista del
inversionista es que solo pueden comprar
o vender al final del día y eso sólo
pasa en el valor unitario de la cuota
parte por acción y encima de todo el
administrador del fondo o quien sea que
se haga cargo de él debe preocuparse por
todas estas transacciones entre todos
estos distintos inversionistas por otro
lado del asunto vimos que los fondos de
inversión cerrada los fondos
de inversión cerrada no pueden crecer o
encogerse tan dinámicamente al crear
nuevas acciones o comprarlas de vuelta
pero lo que era muy bueno de ellos es
que las puedes cambiar o negociar quizás
en otros lados como en la bolsa de
valores de nueva york y debido a que no
había estás estás idas y venidas entre
los administradores del fondo o quien
sea que hiciera las operaciones entre el
fondo y los inversionistas ellos no
tenían que guardar efectivo aparte
verdad y así se ahorraban estos
conflictos con los gastos generales
ahora probablemente dirás bueno que no
habrá alguna forma de obtener lo mejor
de ambos tipos de fondos que pudiera ser
dinámico crecer dinámicamente que
pudiera vender las acciones digamos pero
al mismo tiempo estas nuevas acciones se
pudieran comercializar en un mercado
abierto bueno puedes verlo como una
especie de combinación de los ya
existentes son llamados fondos
negociables en el mercado
y fondos negociables negociables en el
mercado
fnm para más cortos sale y dirá si
espera no es un fondo de inversión
cerrada uno negociable en el mercado y
lo es de hecho estos son negociables en
la bolsa de valores pero oficialmente no
son
fnm así que si alguien te habla de fnm
la manera de pensar los es como una
combinación de ambos pero lo que hace es
limitar las interacciones así cuando
tienes un fondo mutuo de inversión
abierta normal cualquier inversionista
puede venir al fondo y decir aquí está
mi acción cómprame la de vuelta y se
elimina esa acción esto crea un montón
de gastos aquí en un fondo negociable en
el mercado sólo personas autorizadas y
solo bueno generalmente son grandes
instituciones pueden ir al fondo y decir
quiero comprar o redimir un gran bloque
de acciones así un fondo negociable en
vez de crear una acción a la vez puede
crear 5.000 y los 100.000 acciones a la
vez
y por otro lado si alguien quiere
redimir sus acciones y puede redimir
cinco mil diez mil cien mil acciones al
mismo tiempo y lo que es bueno ahí desde
el punto de vista de los fondos es que
no tienen que lidiar con todas esas
pequeñas transacciones pueden hacer
grandes transacciones con grandes
entidades lo que ahorra costos en
general y como estas grandes como estas
grandes personas van a comprar estos
grandes bloques de acciones ellos pueden
ir y venderlas en el mercado abierto
pueden comerciar las en el mercado así
que si quieres puedes comprar acciones
de un fnm en vez de comprarlo
directamente con él
podrías comprarlas en una de estas
grandes instituciones que compran
grandes bloques de acciones así que
ellos compran ya sabes no sean un gran
bloque de acciones 10000 digamos y las
comercian en el mercado abierto porque
así que puedes obtener lo mejor de ambos
mundos y en general
fnm también tiene cuotas más bajas
tienen cuotas más bajas 1 porque no
tienen que hacer tanto jaloneo entre los
inversionistas y la mayoría de los fnm
no están activamente administrados y
cuando digo eso estoy hablando de la
en donde tenías a [ __ ] y [ __ ] dice que
es un increíble negociador que puede
vencer al mercado pueden o sea hacer
todo lo que ya sabemos no él realmente
le da mucho valor al hacer eso cuando
algo no está administrado activamente y
los fondos negociables tienden a no
hacerlo diciendo miren vamos a comprar
el mercado solo vamos a comprar ciertas
comodidades y cuando le entras a los
fondos negociables en realidad solo
trata de comprar cierto tipo de bienes
quizás sea snp 500 quizás algunos tipos
de fondos negociables que compren bienes
en oro o quizás está comprando algún
otro tipo de comodidad por ello no están
administrados activamente el argumento
sería que ellos no hacen tanto como para
para ello así que tendrían cuotas
menores grandes cuotas menores así la
combinación pueden hacerse
arbitrariamente grandes y algunos de los
fondos negociables más grandes son
realmente grandes tienen cuotas mucho
menores y tienen esta comercialización
puedes comerciarlos en cualquier momento
en el mercado no tienes que esperar al
final del día como en un fondo libre de
inversión